[Music]
gotcha we are so excited to have you
today as you can see you've said that
Microsoft's mission is not to be cool
it's to make others cool
but Bob Dylan is playing across campus
today and you sold out faster than him
so we certainly think Microsoft is cool
really though we are so grateful to you
for making the time to be with us and we
have a lot to cover but I thought we
could start with your childhood in India
you've said that your father never met a
test he didn't chase while your mother
was the opposite of a tiger mum I love
that contrast and I'm curious how their
different life philosophies shaped you
first of all thank you so much for
having me here it's great to be at the
GSB and you know Bob Dylan was my idol
so changing the you know it's it's
interesting in fact I just my father
passed away just last month and I've
been reflecting quite a bit on what my
both my parents have meant to me my
father was a Marxist economists and a
civil servant and he had a you know a
definitive point of view on what life
was all about and and the struggle of
life and he's right I mean he you know
the guy always used to look at my marks
I mean my scorecards and and used to be
amazed that somebody could be that bad
and huh and but luckily enough I think
in some sense he gave me in spite of all
of that a lot of confidence because to
him he felt like look it's a marathon
you'll catch up this is not that hard
and my mother was exactly the opposite
of course all the only questions she
would ever ask me is are you happy and I
would say what the heck does that mean
like you know when you're reading my
scorecard I don't know whether I should
be happy or not but again
the two of them I think when I look back
growing up in Hyderabad in India in the
late 70s early 80s interesting enough
there are three or four of us who now
suddenly have become CEOs from the same
high school in this you know at that
time war was off the grid place I think
it was that ability to think that
ability to pursue your own passions and
have you know enough confidence as well
as some humility as sort of when I look
back have been you know perhaps the
biggest drivers of what sort of turned
out to be a reasonable you know set of
things it's it's really clear how much
your parents influenced you and another
foundational influence for you with
sports now my fellow international
classmates and I we're mystified daily
by American sports references so we're
very happy to talk about cricket yeah
you love cricket and you dreamt of
playing professionally what lessons did
you take from the pitch well I mean um
you know all of us your South Asian are
obsessed with that sport and you know
it's sort of in fact that's right I mean
that was what I was pretty much all
bound up in all through my high school
into college and you know when I look
back you know I think all sport teaches
you a lot and especially at least I feel
team sport I think has a huge impact and
how you think about leadership I'll
never forget this one particular
incident that I I think subsequently
written about there was this guy who was
my school captain who went on to do
pretty well in in the context of Indian
cricket I was bowling trash that day and
he took over from me got a wicked which
is a breakthrough but then he gave me
the ball back and then I went on to have
perhaps the best bowling spell I've ever
had in my life and I've always reflected
as to why did he do that and then uh in
fact much later on in life I went back
and asked to me
and so at least the way I surmise it as
a leadership decision he made of saying
look I recognize that this guy's him he
recognizes the importance of not
breaking my confidence and I said look
what that's a pretty enlightened
decision for a high school leader you
know captain of a cricket team to make
and a lot of leadership lessons is that
read which is you got to make hard calls
on say performance but also you gotta be
able to sort of understand that you need
your team and it's not like everybody is
going to have a good day all the time
and that subtle distinction and that
judgment right which is one of the
things that I feel which is the most
understated part of leadership is
judgment and it's so important and that
judgment comes by you exercising this
muscle around passing judgment and
learning from it and I thought that's
one of the lessons I learned he was
building your confidence and okay by
making you that's right so you didn't
end up playing professional cricket Here
I am but you didn't make your way to the
US and soon after you started your own
family and in reading your book
something that really moved me was how
much you talked about your family and
the role they've played bringing empathy
into your life could you share with us
how being a parent has shaped you yeah I
mean it's it's a very big part in a part
of what is perhaps shaped my worldview
and for both my wife and me both my wife
and I grew up together if we went to the
same schools and we were the only
children of our parents so the when we
both later in our late 20s when our
first son was about to be born we were
very excited the household was all about
you know my wife is an architect and so
she was practicing at that time and so
my only concern was or when will and
will go back to school I would I'll go
back to work and how are we going to
think about the baby's daycare and
what-have-you and lo and behold one
night
you know there was some complications
and our son Zane was born because of
some complications he he now has
cerebral palsy he's got as guests
quadriplegia and he's locked in and I
would say for the first maybe as many as
five years I struggled with it primarily
because I felt that all these plans that
I had for what our life was going to be
like had taken a real turn and and then
I watched on who go up and down 520 in
Seattle taking him to every therapy
possible speech occupational and then I
was just watching it and still moaning
uh my own sort of whatever issues but
then it dawned on me ah that nothing
actually happened to me something had
happened to my son and that I needed to
as a father step up and do my duty in
other words it was the harsh but real
lesson around being able to see the
world through the eyes of my son
right that's what empathy is all about
and and I think that's what it is I mean
it's it's innate in us all as humans I
think empathy is something that we are
all very capable of life teaches us that
and in small ways and in in in tough
ways like I remember even the foot the
last interview by the last interviewer
when I was interviewing at Microsoft was
also a life-changing moment for me so I
went through this interview it is all
code on screen at that time and you know
and so this guy sort of says hey here's
a question for you
you're at the crossroads a baby falls
and it's crying what will you do and I
say wow this is some search algorithm I
didn't learn it must be some variant of
some Traveling Salesman problem or
something and I sort of really thought
about it for a few minutes in that I
said I'll go to the phone booth and call
911 pretty smart phone and so he gets up
he escorts me out and he says you know
what you
need to develop some empathy because
when a baby Falls you pick them up and
hug them first before you call ah and I
thought that's it I'm definitely not
gonna get this job and and and lo and
behold I did get the job but
nevertheless I mean I I really think
that that's so core and some people say
well like what what does that have to do
with sort of business or what does it
have to do with work and I believe it
has everything to do with work you know
I believe if you sort of say innovation
is all about meeting unmet unarticulated
needs or customers where is that source
of your ability to get in touch with
that unmet and articulated need going to
come from it's going to come from your
ability to in some sense be able to
listen between the lines to be able to
extrapolate and that's to me deep sense
of empathy right so people talk about
design thinking I think design thinking
is empathy and so therefore I do believe
that you know life teaches you empathy
and you know empathy is the source to
success in any innovative agenda you
have it's inspiring to hear you say that
you think empathy is innate when we're
living in a world where sometimes it
feels like empathy is on the decline so
I think your point around empathy is is
really well taste it's a great question
because in fact you know it is such a
big word and it is hard
in fact even recently at Microsoft we
realized that it's important for us to
even understand what are the necessary
conditions to even develop empathy so
one of the words we have developed you
know we're put into our sort of parlance
is respect for example if you don't
start with from a place or having some
respect for the other person's views
where they come from their complete
history it's very hard to develop
empathy so therefore I think you're
absolutely right to say you know before
you think about so these higher level
things you have to sort of even question
what are the you know basics that we
need to get right and that's become so
core to your leadership at Microsoft so
if we turn now to Microsoft before you
were CEO you took this job leading
Microsoft's first real cloud business
and Steve Ballmer apparently told you
this might be your last job at Microsoft
because if you fail
there's no parachute that feels like a
lot of pressure why did you make that
jump you know you know Steve who wear to
school here had many he just went for
one year from what I understand oh this
is the funniest thing I should tell said
this that means I guess the other guy
who went to school here was Mukesh
Ambani so I believe one day Steve
Ballmer is introducing Mukesh in Bombay
and he joked that both of us dropped out
of GSB except that Mukesh had never told
anybody that he had dropped out of GSB
so there was a real scandal and so Steve
you know wanted us to really take this
new business area which was our online
business in fact Susan who's here and I
worked on it for a long time as well and
he felt that look this is a place where
we needed to make progress and Steve had
this very clear sense so what it means
to succeed and his point was you're
gonna go learn a lot and of course I'll
fire you if you don't do a good job of
it and it was sort of a way for him to
perhaps communicate both why he is the
CEO cared about this business and at the
same time his expectations but I must
say that particular tour of duty has
been the most influential in how I've
sort of thought about whether it's
distributed computing at its core
whether it's the economic models that
are going to be emergent and that has
been very very helpful doing different
things inside the company has helped me
grow to run the company eventually so
you know I actually appreciate Steve
both giving me that opportunity and more
importantly giving me the message that
look at the end of the day it's
performance that matters did you know at
the time that that decision was putting
you on a path to one day becoming the
scene
no way yeah you know most people ask me
this which is like hey did you have a
sense that you'll become CEO no you know
I was first of all we none of us grew up
even to us especially having grown up at
Microsoft I don't think I even thought
of a Microsoft where Bill and Steve were
not actively engaged I mean it is just
not even in the realm of possibility the
thing though I would say especially you
know Business School graduates that are
an ambitious lot and you're all sort of
saying where am I gonna be my CEO it's a
CEO my only advice there would be oh you
know it's like don't wait for your next
job to do your best work that I think is
the crux of it which is if you think
about every job you get as the most
important job and as the thing that is
perhaps your last job but you gave it
all and of course you know from there a
lot of things will happen and that's at
least how I it was not like the job that
I had before becoming CEO I somehow
thought was just to stop on the way to
something else I actually thought that
that was a fantastic job until you know
I got the next job and that next job was
ultimately to become the CEO of
Microsoft and when you took that job you
faced some high expectations
Microsoft is struggling you're following
as you mentioned Bill Gates Steve
Ballmer and many people thought that
this CEO should come from outside so
what did you draw on in that moment yeah
I mean look I'm a consummate insider
I've grown up at Microsoft now 28 years
and I also recognized your point that I
was taking over from Steve and Bill and
Steve even though was not a founder for
he had found a status in the company
bill and Steve built the company Bill
and Paul founded the company and the one
thing that perhaps I was more grounded
having worked with them is as a non
founder CEO I needed to make explicit
some of the things that I think founder
CEOs can take for granted because
founder CEOs can carry
just because of who they are and what
they mean to the organization a lot and
telegraph that very broadly and have
followership whereas I describe myself
as a mere mortal CEO I felt I needed
that sense of purpose to be deeply
rekindled as something that I you know
reinforced and culture both sort of
these two pillars of sense of purpose
and culture needed to become much more
explicit for example when I joined
Microsoft in 92 we used to talk about
our mission as putting a PC in every
home and every desk
it was pretty inspiring right I mean you
could even do an excel spreadsheet P
times Q it was easy to compute and and
except by the late 90s we had more or
less achieved that at least in the
developed world and since then we had
the struggle of what's next
and I felt like I needed to sort of go
back in fact the very origin of the
company right I mean Microsoft got
started when we built a Paul and Bill
built the basic interpreter for the
Altair and I believe that everything
that needs to be known about Microsoft
in 2019 can be traced back to our origin
which is rebuild technology so that
others can build more technology right I
felt like we were doing things out of
envy and others we needed to get back to
what we our core identity is right
especially in 2019 where every company
is a software company around the world
we can just basically be a software
platform and tools provider and have a
good business and so I felt let's be
proud of who we are of course we got to
express it differently and and then you
know would really reinforce that that's
why we talked about our mission around
empowering people in organizations
the other piece though is we had to work
on our culture you know I distinctly
remember I guess it was 98 when we first
became the largest market cap company in
the world and many of us you know we
were lucky enough to participate on that
wave of growth but I remember that day
when we walked around you could see in
the cat you know on campus people
thought wow
be God's gifts to mankind right we're so
smart we're so good look at us and and
except it was not the case I mean the
case was you know it's a temporal thing
and it only matters what matters is your
ability to learn grow be grounded in the
realities and you know and our customers
and what have you and so that's why I
wanted a culture that stood for that
learning organization and in fact my
wife would introduce me to a book by a
Stanford professor Carol Dweck which I
read mindset many years before I became
CEO you know it was a huge influence in
our household as it relates to our own
children's education but quite frankly
it was a great education for me because
when I read that book I realized that
that the notion of growth mindset
applies to individuals like me it
applies to companies like Microsoft so
we took that meme of growth mindset and
said look let's not be know-it-alls
let's be learn it all and has been a
very helpful part of I would say our
journey around this what is a cultural
meme that we can even make first class
that we can have a real dialogue on
absolutely and you talked a lot about
this cultural shift in looking back at
that over the last five years what was
the most difficult part to change
because you've you instilled growth
mindset you did all of these things but
what what would that hardest for
roadblocks it's always it's a challenge
it's one thing to same growth mindset
because sometimes people will come to me
and say that Microsoft Satya we found
the ten people who don't have a growth
mindset the point about that it's not
about going looking for ten people it's
about me being comfortable with
confronting my own fixed mindset each
day and that's the hard part of it when
you say you're a learning organization
and you say we out we've learnt that
here are the ten people who have not
learned then that's a problem and and I
think that that's that the reality of it
right how do you bring about long-term
change I mean I'll say one other thing
one of the reasons why I feel at least
we have some momentum I'm very very
careful not to sort of paint this
some destination we will reach or have
reached for sure it's going to be
something that every day we're gonna
have to confront our fix mind said we're
always going to be imperfect there is
going to be a gap between what is our
espoused sort of culture and what is the
lived experience the question is are we
working to bridge that gap ah and it's
very uncomfortable especially in
business where everything is graded by
you know how close to perfection are you
to say let's be imperfect and celebrate
imperfection it's just a hard thing and
that's why leadership at the top setting
the tone blocking the walk I think is
the hard part but you know anyway that's
the the real I would say challenge of
being able to implement change at scale
absolutely and you know you want to set
this culture of a growth mindset where
people can take risks and make mistakes
and learn from them and you want to walk
the walk the walk when have you had to
lead by example on this front well I
mean every day I would say but I you
know in some sense the the decision ones
makes in like for me the ability to sort
of take even take diversity and
inclusion the the saying the word saying
we're gonna make progress is one thing
and then to recognize that progress has
to be something that really has to come
from one's own first change in behavior
right and take the everyday experience
of the senior leadership team meeting
itself it's an interesting thing every
time I question myself on everything
that we talk about as what we espouse
that is more broadly applicable across
the company how much of it is
represented in the behaviors starting
with me of our own senior leadership
team we have some very very amazing
woman who are part of our leadership
team are they participating like anybody
else and in fact I'm
allowing for them to be able to really
make sure that we are listening to them
they are able to feel like they're
driving the company and and starting
with that type of sensibility which by
the way is not constant but at least
I'll be pushing is sort of the way I
think I remind myself of how important
to your point about it sort of putting
it everyday practice we have three
things that are the cultural I would say
pillars for us right one is diversity
and inclusion the other one is customer
obsession and then the other one is to
bring the company together as one
company as opposed to you know you know
fragmented set up P and Al's all three
of these are just super hard easy to say
but require everyday practice starting
with me and I think diversity and
inclusion is an interesting one because
it's a topic that can invoke a lot of
defensiveness so to apply a growth
mindset to that area is particularly
powerful ya know for example the thing
that we have recognized is you have to
put many of you do a lot of things here
for example we even change the
compensation of our senior leaders
starting or even mine to ensure that we
take this as a huge priority you could
say well you know is the compensation
change the real thing of you know I'm
not saying it's the only thing that
needs to change but it's an important
thing I myself had probably perhaps not
recognize that measuring things having a
real metric around it and then
compensating is actually is a good sort
of start on a lot of fronts and so but
the thing that we have come to realize
is every intern class she joins
Microsoft every year is more diverse
than the previous one but then they look
around and say well where's that
diversity you know in the company and so
that means the real currency of a
culture is inclusiveness and that I
think is the core job of what leaders do
and what is the everyday experience of
you know what happens at Microsoft
interesting enough I have calls that
come to recognize that that
first level manager has probably the
most influence on what happens and so I
I distinctly remember as a lead at
Microsoft with five people working for
me who all were thinking why is this guy
leading us right I mean it's always the
case because the first level job is the
hardest job because there are five
people who are also grad you know just
recent graduates who are sort of looking
at you and saying I can do what you do
and then you have a boss who's asking
you to do many things and so it's sort
of real pressure cooker in the sense you
sort of really have to you know do a lot
but that's when your attitude your
nurturing of that five people who are
working for you around inclusiveness
will matter a lot so one of the things
that we're doubling down is are we truly
supporting managers you know at all
levels to be able to sort of in fact
support their team so that they can
bring the best out of them and then have
them feel included as part of the
company so we've talked a lot about
culture let's shift and talk a bit about
strategy
and particularly the cloud because today
we sort of take the cloud for granted
but when you took over it was still far
from a sure thing and you made this bold
bet cementing Microsoft's strategy in
the cloud how did you rally others
around that vision when many were
convinced it wouldn't work I mean you
know our challenge with the cloud was we
had a very very successful business in
what was the client-server era and sort
of you look at any P&L that says you
know here is a new business by the way
it's God gross margins that are sort of
1/4 of those gross margins or the
current business or and it'll be good
it's hard to sort of look at those kind
of transitions because all rationality
says that you know you should avoid it
as much as possible and except in in
tech in particular and many other
businesses these transitions are secular
they're inevitable and so the question
is you know how do you make that
transition and that's where I must say
Steve when he was a Sea
was the one who gave me permission and
the decision he made was look we want to
go after this and one of the things that
I've realized as leaders and many of you
in your careers are going to make these
kinds of decisions you know we are all
about solving these over-constrained
problem right I mean classic
over-constrained problem is or you have
a huge profit margin and now you got to
go build a new business that sort of
sort of replaces this business and by
the way you should have the same gross
profit margin and guess what it's not
possible
so someone somewhere has to remove some
constraint who does it leaders do it so
he removed the constraint called gross
margin
he said go win this market and that
sward was then made it possible for us
to do all those things that have now
gotten us to the other side but to me
I've learned a lot from that so in fact
if anything I feel like as a leader
sometimes you know you get to speak from
both sides of the mouth right Richie so
I need growth and I need profit in many
cases your job as leaders is to in fact
unconstraint take on the risk now in
fact in the first multiple years amy
hood who's my CFO and myself we said
look let us take on the risk and then
actually met metric a lot of our leaders
more on customer satisfaction usage
versus profit revenue even and I think
that that's sort of the type of
decision-making one needs in order to
make these harsh transitions and when
you look back and you you look at all
that you've done on culture and strategy
and making this bold bet are you able to
tell which one move to the needle more
for Microsoft's renewal I fundamentally
believe that you know strategies or
markets will always be coming and going
there will be lots of changes I'm a
fundamental believer in that sense of
purpose and culture as the two two
pillars that are necessary in order to
get a lot of other things right of
course if you don't get your strategy
right or your ability to sort of ride a
particular wave of innovation and
especially in tech you it's pretty harsh
alright I mean it's very hard to recover
but that said though the question is
what is it that will give you the best
probability of even catching those and
to mean that sense of purpose which i
think is a reflection of what you're
innately good at as an organization
right it's comparative advantage except
it's codified in that identity and
culture is what allows you to express
that identity with new opportunity I
think many of us in this room want to
use our careers to create impact at
scale and you have committed almost 30
years to Microsoft which seems
unfathomable to many of us how do you
think about flies by how do you think
about entrepreneurship and this idea for
those among us who maybe want to work in
large organizations to create change in
the world what advice would you have
yeah I mean I look I mean I think that
you know all organizations small or
large all have amazing opportunities but
I'll make the case for a large
organization and especially an
organization like Microsoft I mean think
about it if you want to have impact at
scale in fact one of the reasons you're
there two things when I'm trying to
recruit at a college I'm always telling
people like hey look if you want to be
cool go join somebody else but if you
want to make others cool join Microsoft
and I say that because I believe that
you know which other organization will
be able to have in a hundred and ninety
plus countries the impact on small
business productivity public sector
efficiency multinationals in any part of
the world and their competitiveness
globally health outcomes education
outcomes this is scale at at you know
enormous rate and so therefore if you
want join a company like this but then
you have to have the following I would
say Sensibility
guess what you got to work with others
ah in other words that's I think a key
important skill like what does it mean I
mean you do a lot of that many of you
have got a lot of
experience even before coming to
business school but never fundamentally
to do anything useful and big and at
scale it's all about teams teams inside
or teams outside that's what it takes
and the second thing that you also need
is to realize that you know a lot of
people talk about the matrix and the
complexity of large organizations that's
again the case I mean even for small
companies you just have a different type
of matrix you'll have a VC you'll have a
board you'll have customers so it's
you're never going to escape working
with people ha you're never going to
escape bringing multiple constituents
together and I think that you should
pick whether whatever size of
organization recognize that scale only
comes because you've been able to bring
many constituents together you say that
we can never escape working with people
which brings me to my next section on AI
you are a big proponent of AI and you
believe that AI will be good for
humankind and you argue that in an AI
future human traits like empathy and
creativity will be more important than
ever and yet in some ways technology has
made us less connected so how do you see
AI augmenting humanity rather than
detracting from it look first of all I'm
excited I'm going to spend some time
with your own work around this human
centered AI and the work you're doing
there I think it's so important here's
how I come at it first before we get it
to get into some of the unintended
consequences of AI one of the areas that
I am deeply involved in is accessibility
right I mean think about what AI is done
to people who need the most help right
say if you have ALS now with eye gaze
you can type and communicate if you have
visual you know impairment of any sorts
you can interpret the world by using the
latest in computer vision if you have
dyslexia be using some mission reading
and comprehension techniques you can
start you know teaching a middle
kid how to read because reading then
leads to their participation in our
economy so I would first say some of AI
and CAI capabilities are helping more of
us participate fully in our societies
and in our economies that doesn't mean
we shouldn't be clear-eyed about the
consequences of AI right the first one
is what are the ethics of AI we as in
fact creators of these platforms and
tools have to even before we even get to
sort of the big topic of ethics improve
the state of the art of the software
engineering around AI so that things
like bias and so on are aren't being
dealt with you know there's this
fantastic line I love all of real case
which is he talks about how the future
enters in you and transforms itself in
you before it becomes real so we are
creating AI it's humans who are creating
the eyes so we get to shape you know
what the craft of creation of AI looks
like how we design systems where the
human is in loop we get to decide that
as a society even what we are
comfortable with and not comfortable
with so I don't want to abdicate all of
that you know and feel like this is just
gonna happen outside of our control so
that's at least how I think about it and
also on the employment side I I do
believe that for example I mean you know
this is it zero-sum I don't think that
is the case I think that there will be
more jobs the question is how do we
really use in fact all of this sort of
levers we have economic and social to
skill people for the jobs that are going
to be there and many of those skills
might be different types of skills than
the ones that are valued today for
example there's no reason why our
society can't have wage support for
teachers in a different way in a world
where there's a lot of abundance of AI
doing a lot of other things for us or
artists or what have you so therefore I
think we will come up with mechanisms
and you know I hope that we have you
and in fact more than hope I feel that
we shouldn't abdicate our responsibility
to control our own future
that I think we all want to live in and
given Microsoft's vision to democratize
AI you know there are concerns about
what might happen if those tools get
into the wrong hands and you've just
mentioned not to abdicate that sort of
responsibility so how do you think about
who to partner with in light of those
concerns right I mean there's multiple
things so one is what is it that we
ourselves will do to in some sense have
some core principles that define what we
do and then who we walk with you know
take facial recognition that's quickly
becoming the topic which i think is
going to even have regulatory frameworks
around it in the state of Washington we
participated even in creation of that
regulation so I think that first before
we what you know even the regulation is
in place we have guidelines on what we
think is the right use because the
maturity of the models really make it
possible you know only sensible to use
it in certain use use cases and not in
others and being clear about it and then
ensuring that that's what we do and then
working knowing that they will be like
there's food safety there should be AI
safety I mean there will be regulation
and we should be okay with it in fact if
anything our practices in our data of
what's good what's not what's the state
of Technology should inform that
regulation so you bring up the topic of
regulation and today it seems that
relationships between regulators and
many large tech companies are fraught
in its early days Microsoft may have
fought its own battles but today
Microsoft is leading with openness and
so what's your advice for the aspiring
tech leaders here on balancing that
pressure to grow as a company with your
responsibility to society that's an
interesting question oh yes here's what
I've at least learned in fact Brad Smith
who's there another colleague of mine
who recently wrote a book called tools
and weapons he reflects because he was
very much part he worked with Bill he
worked with Steve and now he works with
me very much part of our own struggle
I would say the one thing that we at
least I took away from that time is when
there is I'd say a lot of criticism of
whatever it is that you are doing I
think that it's it's it's appropriate
for us to look in the mirror and perhaps
learn about what it is that we are being
criticized about and perhaps there are
changes that we need to actually bring
about so I would say scrutiny of large
organizations is absolutely something
that is going to only happen and I think
large organizations should welcome it
and and we all can learn from it and the
call though especially in technology
business we collectively as an industry
have to just mature and mature at a very
fast rate because the impact of digital
technology in our lives and in our
society is so deep now that for us to
assume that we're just gonna have
unfettered access to all parts without
thinking about the unintended
consequences of this technology are long
gone and so therefore for us is an
industry for us as a company to both
recognize the opportunity of these
technologies and the responsibilities
whether it's in security whether it's in
privacy whether it's in AI and ethics I
think is going to be central and it's me
and these are not going to be terms of
competition even I think this is where
the industry at scale has to get a lot
better and I think that that moment is
is upon us and I do see positive change
but it is definitely a time for
self-reflection and change so I want to
circle back to your own leadership style
and values and what strikes me is that
you seem to combine this sense of self
and ability to stay true to your
leadership style you even have a story
of Steve Ballmer telling you it's too
late to be different with on the other
hand this real belief in a growth
mindset and I think for many of us at
the GSB there's this question
how do you stay true to your own style
while still knowing when and how to grow
in the right direction and so how do you
think about those two things I mean yeah
I mean I think the ability to understand
yourself is is actually it's a
lifetime's journey right it's a journey
of your lifetime to really unpack who
you are and what you're good at
what makes you take what are your
passions is something that what makes
you happy the question that my mother
asked me all the time and in fact the
more the older I get the clearer I am in
in understanding even what she was
asking and then to be able to understand
others that's also another journey of a
lifetime right which is you sort of feel
like you understand what others is
saying you understand where they're
coming from I think that's really what
is going to perhaps help you with both
be true to yourself your identity what
makes you tick what makes you happy
while knowing that ultimately I think a
lot of that satisfaction you get is
because of your ability to empathize the
ability it could be your family it could
be your workplace that's the other thing
that I've come to realize it's be can be
transactional at work I'll tell you
there was this gentleman and another GSB
grad whom I worked for Doug burgum who's
actually the governor of North Dakota
nowadays but there was this time you
know in my mid-30s he said something to
me which just had a profound impact he
said look you're gonna work you know at
Microsoft more time then you were gonna
even spend with your kids and I said oh
wow that's pretty you know that sounds
pretty harsh and and yet it is true
his main point was you better think
about work having deeper meaning than
being transactional and and as I've
thought about that the only way it's not
going to be transactional is when you
relate to people you work with and you
know that's what you'll remember the
projects you worked on the technologies
will all be passe in time but the people
what you did how you behave what was
your you know I take great pride in
these people whom I mentor or go on to
do great things that's the relationship
that I think you seek out while being
true to yourself and what makes you
happy and you mentioned humility earlier
and how important it is to you and you
have this quote that says when everyone
is celebrating you is when you should be
most scared and I think it's safe to say
that people are celebrating Microsoft's
renewal so how do you keep yourself and
your team's grounded among the six great
that's great that's a great question you
know there's this book I recently read
by David Brooks called a second mountain
it was an interesting book because he
talks about it mostly in the context of
us you know there's that first Mountain
which is what perhaps many of you as
graduates of GSB are going to be on and
you're going to seek excellence and
success in the professional career and
then you're eventually going to get to
that second mountain and then you're
going to sort of in his words relate to
the world and community and what have
you and I feel that that's really what's
there for Microsoft the way you know
having gotten to whatever high market
cap in 98 now for us it's more not our
market cap but what is our market cap
leading to to your point it's if you
celebrate our success but real but
fundamentally realize if you sort of go
back to our mission and our business
model right it's not even a sense of
mission and purpose that somehow
abstracted away from what's core driving
our business model
we need to see success all around us
that's it and so if we celebrate that
small business in Kenya or that large
multinational in Sweden or that public
sector company in Indonesia and Vietnam
that's what's going to help us be
grounded and be successful and so that
invoking of that everyday sense of
purpose is what I think is going to help
us the most
thank you such a and I think on that
note we will turn it over to some
questions from the audience hi my name
is tarik Arad peer and I'm a first year
MBA student and I'm asking this question
in conjunction with my classmate Jeff
Krueger who unfortunately couldn't be
here but we're both interested you've
mentioned that I'm Microsoft you've made
a principled decision that you're not
going to withhold technologies from
institutions that have been elected in
democracies to protect the freedoms we
enjoy this position as you probably know
stands in contrast to a number of your
peer tech companies here in the valley
can you elaborate on your decision
framework as CEO to have Microsoft
pursue US Department of Defense
contracts like the Jedi cloud project at
DoD yeah I mean first of all you know
one of the things that we're engaged in
is with deep respect for all opinions
that people may have on things that we
should be concerned about but on this
one we've been very clear from day one
on the statement you read out which is I
feel that I have great belief in our
democratic institutions and our
democratic process and one of my big
fears is that somehow CEOs or
corporations try and substitute for what
I think in the long run is the most
important thing for us which is our
democracy to work as design and in this
case if we don't like what our
government does we have this one great
opportunity which is we get to change we
get to vote we get to even take
principled stance
against our government if we do think
that that is something that we want to
fight for in fact Microsoft whether it's
in the previous administration or this
administration we've had cases you know
it was the warrant case or on privacy is
something that we were able to go fight
and then ultimately through the cloud
act bring about change which was a
bipartisan legislation which I feel is a
good step in the direction of having
privacy enshrined in a legislative sort
of press set of processes so that's how
I look at it I don't see how withholding
technology from as I said the
institutions that we have elected there
are subject to civilian control
ultimately to protect the freedoms we
enjoy is going to help that doesn't mean
we shouldn't have ethical principles we
shouldn't ED advocate for ethical
principles and in fact these
institutions that we are talking about
have perhaps a more of a history around
these ethical principles as well and so
for us to rely on that and reinforce
that I think it would be important I
shan't
I'm from Hyderabad the second EMU
straight city so my question is today if
you were a 22 year old engineering
graduate from India will you come would
you stay back in India and work in the
tech and startup because the stem or
would you come to the US and why and if
you come to the US how can we all think
of contributing back to our home country
yeah you know yeah it's interesting one
I mean III really literally growing up
never thought I'll ever go outside of
Hyderabad I had very I would say very
self satisfying sort of goals in life I
wanted to play cricket and work for a
bank
and
and things changed look I I feel that
the opportunity whether it's up in India
or rest of Asia or in Africa one of them
we just created to deaf development
centers in Africa both on the west and
the east side of you know because of
Africa there is great opportunity
there's great talent I think digital
technology in particular is a real
democratizing force we were talking even
backstage about how even when the rest
of the infrastructure is challenged
there is very novel ways for digital
technology to overcome some of those
things because of the the most valuable
nature of software in some sense so
therefore I think there's opportunity
everywhere in the world but at the same
time for you to come here learn from you
know learn in a place like the GSB and
be inspired and go back is an
opportunity you I would take if that
sort of came or about but at the same
time it doesn't mean that that's the
only opportunity I had to have an impact
you know it's interesting you bring up
because globalization let's face it is
going through a little bit of a
challenging phase and I think that it's
deserved in some sense because the
globalization was celebrated to a point
where the you know inequities that were
getting you know founded I guess or
inequities that developed in local
communities were not addressed whatever
happens in this next phase of
globalization will not only in fact help
that grand convergence of opportunity
all over the world which was by the way
a very good thing in that first phase of
globalization but also address the local
inequities whether it's in India or in
in Palo Alto I think that that's what I
think is needed whereas there is real
innovation that brings equitable growth
everywhere is perhaps the opportunity
for GSB grads in 2019
hello hi I'm Casey Lewin who an MBA - I
also worked at Microsoft before I came
here I think I might be the only one not
that team let's go that's great
I was just wondering in your rise to the
top what was the biggest adjustment you
made to your leadership style as you
move up in the company you know it's
interesting I must say there's many many
dimensions perhaps the biggest
adjustment was that ability to grapple
with what is it that uniquely only you
can do versus what others in the team
can do getting much better at it was the
most helpful but the CEO job when I look
back at it and many of you who may you
know start out and you know and become
even see you as much earlier on in your
career I had not understood perhaps even
growing up at Microsoft how multi
constituent the job is right I mean
that's perhaps the biggest adjustment
I've had to make is recognizing it's
about customers it's about partners it's
about all your employees it's about your
investors
it's about governments it's about many
many many of these constituents and by
the way it's not about like I'll you
know you know it's not like office hours
for each one of them it is about all of
them all the time and how to think about
that multi constituent world I think is
perhaps the biggest adjustment that one
makes as you grow in any organization
and the faster you grapple with it the
better off you will be in your
organization will be so will now turn it
back to our traditional lightning round
and don't be scared we're changing it up
a little bit this time I'm going to ask
you to complete a few sentences for me
so I feel most energized when I see
someone very excited about the impact of
what they're doing
what keeps me up at night is what wakes
me up in the morning goodgoodgood dodge
there I am most grateful for the the
sense of the the love the affection of
people that I've had the good fortune
whether it's my family whether it's the
people I've come across at work the
organizations that I'm involved in it's
it's just such a blessing when I look
back that's the thing that sort of
really I'm most thankful for for the
people in my life in all spheres of it
the most important piece of advice I
could leave this audience with is is the
a piece of advice that Steve Ballmer
gave me when I became CEO be bold and be
right which is if you're not bold you're
not going to do much of anything and if
you're not right it you won't be there
sorry thank you so much it's been a real
[Applause]
[Music]